cela faisait presque un an que ces
petits vendômois n'était pas venu voir
un spectacle avec leurs centres de
loisirs la chapelle saint-jacques à
vendôme a été aménagé pour permettre le
respect des distances sociales
ils vont pouvoir assister au conte
musical de rôle
en deux mots comme inspecteur des
feuilles et des spectacles c'est triste
spectacle joyeux fait bien parce
qu'après ça me rappelle un peu des
souvenirs de notre époque d'avant ça
fait bien ça t'a manqué les spectacles
avec le call it c'était compliqué et du
coup la même pour travailler cet été
quand on a travaillé on a quasiment
aucune sortie 6 dans les bois pas très
loin mais sinon c'était vraiment entre
nous et du coup là on commence à pouvoir
et ça fait du bien de rôles fans de moon
est né de l'imagination d'antonin
pernand un concert électro pop où chaque
morceau est un tableau haut niveau pour
l'association figures libres maintenir
le festival les recommander à mon
d'hommes étaient essentielles malgré les
jauge réduite et les règles sanitaires
il y aura un petit déficit ça ne mettra
pas non plus en péril l'association du
lorrain difficile c'est clair ces gens
là pour qu'ils fassent des cachets
jusqu'à août prochain pour pouvoir
renouveler leur status nous appartenait
souche était important en tant que co
organisateur et l'opérateur culturel
également de participer à cette relance
entre guillemets en tout cas ce maintien
de la vie culturelle et c'est aussi pour
public ces partis flamands importance
étant complexe merco motive avant baume
dure jusqu'à samedi
ce jeudi la chapelle saint-jacques
changera d'ambiance avec les blind
riders au programme rockabilly country
et moore ce sera à 15h30